here's the story of how Brian Armstrong  founded coinbase shortly after finishing  College Brian would decide to take a  one-year trip to Buenos Aires Argentina  and this trip would turn out to be  extremely influential you see Argentina  has been struggling with a chronic  inflation problem for decades living in  Buenos Aires Brian was witnessing this  crisis firsthand and this didn't give  him a particularly positive view towards  fiat currency after Brian returned to  the U.S he started working with Airbnb  under International Payment Systems this  experience made him realize just how  difficult it was to send and receive  money in certain developing countries  and this would give him the final push  he needed to go all in on coinbase